yo what up guys this is a mashup the
team's putting together of our empathy
wine kind of telethon infomercial QVC
session some of the best notes best
highlights and most of all if you watch
this please go to empathy wines calm and
order now you got your prospective
[Applause]
[Music]
anything for you oh yeah so like I did
like the button taking cell phone I'm
not sure exactly where I want to do you
I'm just kind of how old are you perfect
man it's early bro 27 is a tricky year a
lot of people get confused because like
they see 30 it's not far away they don't
think they're a kid anymore I need to
rewrite society on this you're a kid
until you're 45 like you're early bro
yeah what did you give I guess for me I
had all the time I did like businesses
and like I would pick one this is with
the bells ringing out maybe people are
hearing me so you pick one and you do it
and you do it for six months to a year
and if you like where it's going you
keep doing it if not you take those
experiences and you pick the next one
literally right down with your homies
the nine ideas put in a hat pull one and
[ __ ] start at the next day this is a
world of action not [ __ ]
contemplation okay of course dude
because because you're worried about
failing right people disguise perfection
and contemplation on their fear of
failing just [ __ ] go bro these are
nine loosened bro you have 47,000 ideas
there's 800 billion things you could be
doing but you picked 9 all of them are
good Angela
Oh Angelique I want to call you and
thank you thank you so so much for
ordering the wine it means a lot a lot
to me yeah what's going on anything I
can answer for you basically I'm an
esthetician I do our last extensions
yep and I'm like crazy well first of all
let me just there's so many people right
now that are crazy booked cutting hair
making a painting doing nails doing I
extension doing massages doing
meditation services immediately
immediately and this is how you're gonna
make all your money back on the wine you
just bought you have to raise your price
tomorrow if you are overbooked and you
have demand you have to read how much do
you cost well there's like fill just
like balances for nails and full sets so
if they don't have any anything on it's
165 if they're coming for a fill it's 50
they start at 50 you have it goes up $10
each week they wait you have to you have
to have to raise your price base your
base price you have to okay I mean
you're overbooked right right that's
what everyone says to do and I know but
all these girls are doing it illegally
just to make money and like doing it for
cheap out of their basement so that it
like listen to me listen to me and I and
I play basketball and the Brawn gets
paid a billion to play it like I don't
don't don't worry about price worry
about supply and demand if you're in
demand guess what people give speeches
on business for free I'm a hundred fifty
thousand do you understand yeah I don't
give a [ __ ] if they're doing it
illegally in the alleys behind your
house do not factor other people's
prices
into your strategy and the supply in the
band of you okay do you understand yeah
I'm telling you right now I'm gonna
check your [ __ ] I'm gonna have somebody
weird I'm just telling you I'm giving
you a preview I'm gonna have somebody
call you right it's gonna be Trouty in
like a woman's voice cuz he's got a
girly voice those were like hey and he's
gonna try to set up an appointment and
if you tell me your prices that you just
quoted we're finished you and I and
you're not gonna know when it's gonna
happen
it's probably not gonna happen tomorrow
but it could happen at any time
and I'm telling you right now it will be
the greatest decision you make and the
reason I'm excited about this advice is
I know I have thousands of people
watching on Facebook and Instagram and
for a lot of people they're scared to
raise their price it's the most common
one woman one man show issue out there
but if you're [ __ ] booked if your
phone's ringing if people are sliding
into the DM and trying to do business if
you're getting asked and you don't have
time to do it you have to raise your
price you're raising your price tomorrow
I'm telling you right now
tomorrow you're raising your price the
next person asked not 165 they're $1.99
and when they say no I don't want to
hear [ __ ] re ve gave me the wrong advice
cuz that's only a focus group of one
right until you get 39 noes in a row you
haven't hit the wrong price are you
scared to raise your price don't lie no
I'm not my price I've known I should be
doing it for awhile but like I said it's
just hard when everyone else is lower
you know what did we say we don't
[ __ ] care about anybody else we spit
on everybody else
we don't even
knowledge their existence I don't even
know any other agency any other wine any
other sneaker I don't even know of
everybody asked me last night Gary what
do you think about the Patriots I'm like
I don't give a [ __ ] it has nothing to do
with me yeah yes I like you already
so do you understand though listen
tonight is the phone call you this is
why I always say doing the right thing
is the right thing you
unlike the thousands of people that are
watching that have gotten tons of money
out of my free advice you've decided to
actually support me in return which I
thank you for that is doing the right
thing I then keep you on the phone and
I'm making I'm not just mailing this
call in I'm making sure that this
fundamentally this call changes your
career I mean Facebook attribution in
terms of like how things are doing they
can give you a sign but obviously I
think going and it's been helping but is
there anything in terms of specifically
frequency I got one for you how many how
many different pieces of content are you
running ads against no no the end the
end the biggest secret in 2019 to
Facebook to make it work better for
people that have started to do it a
little bit is more content volume of
content you're targeting in the area of
Chandler or Arizona or Pacific Southwest
like it's it could be right but if the
content is garbage then you're gonna
lose or if you've run the content to
people and they've seen the same ad over
and over literally one adjective can
change the outcome yes making the
content more narrow and the targeting
more out narrow paying more CPMs but
getting the business result you're
looking for right got it the answer is
the content not the media that's where
people are getting [ __ ] up right and
how much the what preventive is
advertising do you think
increment water I mean I mean it depends
on a business you know like every
business you need to run it like I don't
care if somebody runs 80 percent of
their money on direct mail if they've
spent so much money and tried so many
things that it's proven that that's
better so there's no right answer there
but my big thing is if you haven't
really run the volume of content game on
Facebook you've got to really really ask
yourself you know I have no emotion
I have no motion I just want results
right I don't give a [ __ ] about Facebook
and Instagram I give a [ __ ] about
results I just know that Facebook and
Instagram ads are grossly underpriced
for the attention they give you back but
if you don't know what to fill that
attention with a lot of people could be
live-streaming right now if John and
Nate were live-streaming right now for
em 50 wines we would have sold one
[ __ ] Bell anything I can answer for
you right now um what's your take on
humor and business intersecting uh give
me a little more color on that meaning
like I think humor is a foundational
characteristic that always plays in
society but what do you mean no so I
mean I I totally understand like when
you starting out like young business
going super niche is like a smart
approach okay but when you try to be
more of a generalist when you starting
out you're talking a lot of different
industries there are certain like
fundamentalistic traits like lean into
okay my mind humor is an amazing one to
you like take advantage of so I guess
like like where does that fall worth
like being like not taking seriously as
you're developing yourself
oh dude like dude like light ice we were
saying now life is always about the end
result like people said to me I would
not be taken seriously because I cursed
if you can bring it everything's taken
seriously like that's that's the that's
the right take like that's the absolute
right take the end cool all right
brother thank you bro keep being funny
seeing Atlanta got it talk to you hey
how are you I am fantastic
thank you so much for supporting empathy
wines calm unlike
many people here I can't wait to get my
first case thank you so much is there
anything I can answer for you
no just I want to tell you I'm a Tom
Sara coaching client with a note yeah I
do and house realist their real estate
is great in fact the guy I opened up my
own independent office in Rio with Tampa
Bay free and I'm a licensed broker in
Missouri and Kansas for you but really I
have to confess I started watching The
Good Wife around the holiday time on
that Swift and now I've got this really
bad addiction well here's the good news
here's the good news you're gonna give
me an opportunity to create clarity you
can watch Netflix 24/7 365 if you're
happy the people that I you know to me
the people that I go after on Netflix or
video games or or by the way I watch the
Jets for three hours you know 16 Sundays
a year my big thing is if you're
complaining or you're saying that you're
gonna build a billion-dollar Empire then
you've got to put in hard work if you're
unhappy here's what scares me Lydia like
most people that are unhappy use Netflix
or fortnight or gambling or alcohol or
reading books to escape their truth yeah
so for me it's why not make your life
actually happy and do things you like
and live within the means of the things
that you like where you can earn income
so that you don't need to use those
things to escape your truth so like to
me I love people that watch binge watch
Netflix and are equally happy like that
means you're finding the balance of
escapism and fulfilment pair from the
parents
no you don't know you know this is the
number one mistake that everybody thinks
everybody thinks that they put them
their own self doubt on themselves it's
actually not how it works outside forces
got into your head and then made you
self doubt you think it's your voice
nobody's voice hates them in the
beginning it's a voice that's been
implanted in you either in the beginning
from your neighborhood and outside force
often parents and so where people get
really [ __ ] up is they think like like
when I talk about like don't listen to
the Joneses they're like [ __ ] you know I
don't care about other people it's that
I [ __ ] on myself and I'm trying to get
people understand you're not [ __ ] on
yourself you've taken on the voice of
somebody from the outside you weren't
born with like I hate me you were you've
taken on the voice of somebody from the
outside it's very important that you
understand this I'll tell you why it
gets a lot easier if you actually
believe it and understand it because
then you can understand it versus laying
there and being like why do I hate
myself you know what I mean you don't
somebody implanted their insecurities on
you it's what it's why a lot of people
get value out of me because through my
practical optimism not my delusional
urine eighth-place trophy but for my
practical optimism if people keep
putting that voice in their ears the
reason people listen to so much of my
content is I'm optimistic but I'm not
gonna sugarcoat and be like if you just
wish it it happens and in that balance
over time if that's what goes into your
ears then all of a sudden you start
believing it like I genuinely believe it
I believe that the two of us should
never dress like doubt ourselves why
like I don't understand like go do and
deal with the rant like I think I suck
in most things but I need to go find
that out for myself not not do it
because I'm worried about somebody
judging me on my failure
you're a hundred percent in charge to
like people like you know one of the
things that especially when you're
younger like if you like the fact that
you just said that like I understand
that like like a lot of conversation in
my own family is like how us three kids
took on different traits from our
parents but the reality is like the that
you're just fundamentally in control
there's a ton of things that I'm similar
to my parents on there's things that I
decided to audit and over time chip away
at by just talking about it you know
like if you talk to yourself about it
like everything is solvable I just
really believe that like it just is like
it just it just depends on what you're
willing to listen to like if you listen
to your aunt who says you've taken on
the worst things of your parents you're
gonna lose I don't know what to say like
like like this is just the way it is I
just I'm just really happy that you're
even like like that we're interacting
this much because like honestly I just
you know it's funny I just want people
to listen to me as much as possible
until they don't need to listen to me
and then I don't want them to listen to
me at all I appreciate that so let's
talk about it so there's obviously
there's obviously this circle right like
they're like internships team Gary then
there's companies that involved
but I got to tell you like the thing
that I'm most proud of is that I'm
making myself outrageously accessible
right like look look what I'm doing
right now
like I know buddy's trying harder to
create access for their community I'm
one human and there's only so much I can
do but I promise you like this is just
the beginning like I'm gonna do this for
the next [ __ ] 50 years more
importantly listen to me this is binary
you need to act if you actually if used
this time that we've interacted this
time to understand that any level of
self-doubt or insecurity that you have
in your head is literally been put
inside of it and it's not you doing it
to you it will change your [ __ ] young
life hey guys thank you so much for
watching my video on YouTube I wanted to
jump in here at the end because I'm
working on a ridiculously important
project for me and I have a funny
feeling you can help if you drink wine
at all or know anybody that drinks wine
at all please go to empathy wines calm
right now and sign up for a subscription
whether it's a three pack whether it's a
six pack or whether it's a whole case of
each for the year if you drink 36
bottles of wine a year or give away 36
bottles of wine a year please sign up
for Club empathy this project means the
world to me I could really use your
support
[Music]